[Music]
hey
here we are once again yeah the hell day
is it tuesday
yeah it's tuesday i'm just starting to
get over this cold
i think you had the rona no
everything is corona virus there's 19 of
them [ __ ]
well i'm just saying that because she
said you couldn't taste anything
couldn't taste anything couldn't really
smell anything
it's getting it's starting to come back
but it doesn't feel like a forest fire
in my [ __ ] nose anymore
yeah tomorrow i'm hoping i'm hoping that
i'll just i'm hoping i'll feel
normal tomorrow but almost felt good
almost felt like i want to go out and do
something
yeah yeah not quite but getting there
man it was cold as [ __ ] outside this
morning i mean for florida
i think it was 450 degrees but it was
like the the wind was super cold
yep but i had a good time last night you
watched this movie
it's called love monsters yeah this new
movie
it's pretty good it's pretty good that's
pretty good actually um we just picked
this one out because it looks
you know fun and uh i had heard like a
little bit about it like people talking
about it
i guess it was supposed to come out last
march like march of 2020 yeah and then
it just kept getting pushed back and
then finally they were just kind of like
okay we're just releasing it to vod
in october and then they released it to
some theaters as well
now when they first released it to vod
it was like the number one
rental for a while like on apple tv and
stuff
and you can kind of see why this is kind
of one of those
just sort of feel good family-friendly
action-adventure type movies kind of
like jumanji
yeah kind of like turbo kid if you like
turbo kid you'd like it
um kind of a guy goes on his hero's
journey it's first of all the apocalypse
happens which always like that's
post-apocalyptic
um the earth gets destroyed by [ __ ]
giant monsters
and they explain how that happened but
it's kind of got a good sense of humor
it's a lot of comedy in it
and uh kids spent about seven years
inside the damn fallout shelter trying
to survive
and he's got to get out of his fault
fall out shelter
cross uh i think what was it 12 miles no
it was 85 85 miles okay
yeah 85 miles of uh dangerous
countryside
to go to another shelter where his uh
where a girl he met
seven years ago well his girlfriend his
ex girlfriend seven years ago
so the thing is he's kind of a wuss so
he's got to get out
and [ __ ] learn survival skills well
it wouldn't be fun if he was a badass
yeah
there's no character growth right the
kind of
it's kind of like uh i guess you could
say it's kind of like the hero's
journey of a [ __ ] like uh
developmentally delayed young
guy which is i think a lot of these he's
supposed to be 24 but he's kind of like
a 15 year old
yeah because he went into the bunker
when he was like 16 or 17 and like he
saw his parents get killed like right
before he got
dragged off to the bunker yeah so he
hasn't really
moved on from there yes there's kind of
a
kind of an element of you know these
young guys growing up in their mom's
basement playing video games it's kind
of
he's got to go out into the world and
actually do [ __ ] it's kind of got that
angle but there's also a kind of angle
of where
if you're a 15 year old boy watching the
damn movie you'd be able to
you know i mean you'd be able to kind of
relate to this
24 year old i think that's 24 year old
guy you know so i i don't know did you
did you pick that up
did you see it that way it's what it
seemed like to me i guess sort of yeah
yeah
it just seems like a pretty standard
like i said like a like a hero's journey
just an action adventure just kind of
fun like i said it reminded me of
jumanji or mike gave me a little bit of
a tremors vibe
yeah it had good music a lot a lot of
rock music and music from the [ __ ]
past would pop
up um yeah had that uh this is the day
by the the which
i really like that song that was in
there michael rooker was in it but i
fell asleep right after he came in
i can't believe you'll sleep for about
10 minutes and because you were laying
there and then i was like
hey yay michael rooker because you know
who doesn't love michael rooker he's a
delightful human being and so when he
turned up in the movie i was like
hey michael rooker and then i was like
oh he's asleep yeah well i was
i was sick you know i was kind of tired
you know i didn't realize she was
passed on i'm like you're not excited
about michael rooker what the [ __ ] yeah
dozed off for a few minutes and then
[ __ ] snapped out of it and i
then i think that by the time you woke
up i think his part was his part was
over yeah
yeah cause it didn't matter that it's
not like it was a super intellectual
intellectual movie you know what i mean
you had to pay attention to every little
bit of yeah
it was pretty simple it's it's just like
for the kids
well the kid's name is joel i think not
it's not necessarily what happened
um the the apocalypse was caused by
so i guess it was an asteroid that was
going to hit earth
and the humans like successfully shot
the asteroid
but then the fallout from all the pieces
of the asteroid
caused um all the i guess it's all the
cold-blooded animals or insects
as well um to mutate and get really big
so all the monsters on earth are either
like insects or there's like big huge
giant frogs there's
big huge giant snails crabs big crabs
like all that kind of stuff so it's not
like
you know it's it's not like big bears or
anything like that but it's usually any
like
cold-blooded kind of you know or lesser
animals or whatever i guess
so they all got really big and ate
most of the people so all the people
that are left are just in these colonies
like fallout you know what i mean where
everybody just lives in these like
underground bunkers
and you know they're trying not to get
out so the thing that happens is that
like i said he's been in this bunker for
seven years
all of the other people in the bunker
they like him but they think he's kind
of useless because he has a thing where
he freezes up when he's afraid
um so they're like so they can't take
him like out on
raids and stuff like that because he's
gonna get his ass eaten
so um that sounded dirty
somebody said this kind of sounds like
damnation alley uh i think
did louis say that yeah yeah a lot of
people have compared it to zombieland
too it does have a zombie
kind of kind of vibe to it also yeah no
a lot better
than damnation alley a lot better
damnation alley that you know that that
was the [ __ ] that was
uh late 70s or early 80s that was a
[ __ ] flop
i'll tell you but i kind of liked that
yeah i kind of liked damnation
alley in its day um
it not as good as omega man though mega
man was a lot better
yeah those two movies i kind of to me
they kind of felt alike but
no you probably like it better it's more
like a kid's movie damnation alley
wasn't
yeah yeah i don't even what happened in
that damnation alley yeah it was the
guys that lived in the nuclear
the nuclear missile silo base and uh
they had to leave for some reason i
think they just said [ __ ] it it sounds
familiar and they had this damn
special survival vehicle 1977 77
yeah then the special [ __ ]
apocalyptic survival
uh vehicles kind of like because of
course yeah arc ii yeah
it's kind of like that look at that
giant [ __ ] armored rv
i think it was even hinged in the middle
or i don't remember that was r2 i think
they had that one
and uh each wheel in the cell had
three wheels in it and it would turn and
it could swim and it could do all kinds
of [ __ ]
had missiles and radar and they decided
to
go across country i forgot where it was
they were going to go but there was
giant scorpions and [ __ ]
roaches that ate all rubber and every
[ __ ]
type of material they got attacked by a
swarm of roaches there was just all
kinds of cool [ __ ]
you know if the apocalypse involves
giant roaches i'm out
they weren't giant i i don't want
anything to do with that they were used
they used those madagascar roaches yeah
but um
still that's pretty there were lots of
them and they had eaten every bit
of [ __ ] rubber or any kind of [ __ ]
cloth or anything out of the entire city
they didn't know it and they uh
somebody went into a car and i can't
remember what happened
but a huge [ __ ] swarm of them came
out of the damn
sewer that was yeah they were trying
they were getting
trapped one guy got trapped in a vehicle
in a bit just
swallowed up the whole vehicle and 80 my
you know eating wipes in there
yeah it's just pretty it had some good
ideas the problem was that it was
very ambitious for the time you know
what i mean and it was like they
probably didn't have that didn't have
the budget for everything
i mean i think it had jan michael
vincent in it yeah somebody said that
and george papyrus yeah yeah he was in
it and
okay i don't think i've ever seen that
yeah damn nationality i just i i maybe i
just saw the cover in the video store or
something because the title sounds
familiar
yeah and at night they had the sky was
like a bunch of [ __ ] pink
lightning and stuff you know what i mean
from the from the radio from the
from all the [ __ ] damage that the
nuclear war had done it's pretty cool
yeah yeah it was i had to go back and
see it again
damnation that now i'm plugging damn
nation alley it's probably not as cool
as you remember
because it came out in 1977 yeah no i
remember it
i saw it it wasn't all that great i
finally saw it with me
maybe but it's like it's really not
ringing a bell usually you can see that
one for free
all right now i have to like look it up
and see yeah
but i don't know well that well this one
is more like
i forgot to mention other than michael
rooker who kicks ass
um the best character in this is the dog
i love the dog in this movie his name is
boy
and basically joel the guy that's on
this quest
like i said he's in the um bunker and
the bunker is like starting to get
breached like some of the monsters and
like some of the survivors get killed
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so he decides since everybody else in
the bunker has
you know a partner and he doesn't have
one and he still misses the girl from
seven years ago and she's 85 miles away
in another colony
so he's like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna go
out by myself
you know and but i'm gonna man up and
i'm gonna go find her and
go stay with her at her colony so he
decides he's gonna do that
when he's out there he um he finds this
bus and i guess the person that was
that lived in the bus got killed or
whatever and their dog
is still in the bus so he ends up like
befriending the dog
and the dog actually ends up saving his
ass a couple times and he
um that's how he gets over his fear by
like saving having to save the dog
because the dog is going to get eaten by
one of the monsters and he actually like
nuts up and saves the dog
uh in a very very heartwarming scene
which i liked but the dog in this is
[ __ ] great
so this it reminded me too of like a boy
and his dog
except i think i like this better but um
but i was i gotta say too like the
monsters in this are really really good
especially that first monster was like a
big giant frog with the tongue
and they have like big they had a big
snail
that was really cool but yeah like the
monster designs in this are really
really good and i like like the crab at
the end
yeah they had a grab boy in it pretty
much he was kind of yeah it was kind of
like a gravel
like i said some of them have had like a
tremors kind of vibe to it this had a
tremors kind of vibe to it a little bit
but not it's it's weird because it's
like it's a comedy but it's not
over-the-top zany or over-the-top funny
like in the way maybe jumanji
is it was kind of more like like turbo
kid
it was more like turbo kid where it
wasn't super funny it was kind of like
it had like a lot of heart to it and it
was like really just a good natured
yeah just action adventure kind of movie
and a lot of it was just him
kind of learning how to survive out in
the world like michael rooker and the
little girl that's with him they teach
him all this survival stuff and they
teach him about all different the
all different monsters like what kills
them and all this other kind of stuff
and how he uses that knowledge like as
he goes on so it's just like a hero's
journey like i said
so you know excuse me
it was just like a really fun enjoyable
kind of movie even though it's like
post-apocalyptic which is depressing but
it's other than that it was
i don't know it was super fun it was up
there with you know like i said jumanji
and turbo kid
and and this was shot in australia too
that might be why it's reminding you of
turbo because the
because the uh landscape and [ __ ] like
that was [ __ ] gorgeous i think it was
shot in queensland
i think out of all of them though i'd
probably you know like if you like
those movies see this one but if you
haven't but um
if you haven't seen turbo kid you want
to see that um but uh
out of the two i'd probably give it to
turbo kid i think turbo kid was
yeah i think i liked turbo kit a little
bit better but i think that if you like
turbo kid you would probably like this
one as well because it's got like a
similar
size to it right this was called monster
problems
turbo kid had really good writing
there's something about the writing and
it just felt very organic
yeah and i think because it had a lot of
practical effects in it and i liked that
i liked the story i liked the acting in
it and just
turbo kid kind of felt like an 80s movie
it really did i mean they did a good job
on that
i liked it yeah now i kind of want to
see it again yeah we see it again
was it on where did we see that i don't
remember this one we rented on what xbox
we rented this on the xbox yeah it's
like four bucks five years yeah i think
you can rent it um it might be you can
probably run on amazon prime too it was
kind of everywhere
but yeah we rented it for like i think
it was four dollars on uh
xbox somebody asked me yesterday uh and
i wrote it down so
for that i don't know if they're here
but they asked me yesterday but right
before we
logged off so i didn't get a chance to
answer it what we thought of the
paranormal activity movies
um so i thought i would answer that for
if that person
is still curious about it i have to say
i
i've only seen the first one i think i
might have seen the second one um
but i don't it didn't make much of an
impression uh the first one was actually
pretty good
i'm not a humongous fan of found footage
um but it was done well for that genre i
have seen some found footage movies that
i liked
but i'm not into that genre at all those
movies didn't make any impact on me
if i'm gonna like found footage i i tend
to like
like mockumentaries you know what i mean
like lake mungo or something like that
um now some found footage like
poughkeepsie tapes i think that was
really good
but it can be done well but like i said
i like mockumentary stuff like
the bay or something like that which is
more like a fake documentary i never
even saw the
blair witch product project now i did i
did like blair witch projects i
i've heard that that's the best of best
one i mean you know what i mean i
haven't seen it in a long time but i
remember really really liking it i think
it helps to
i saw it in the theater so that might
help also
um i think a lot of it had to do with
the timing of
the release that came out it was a new
thing yeah it was kind of like a new
yeah not a new genre the way the way the
medium was at that time
it was just a really good time for it
and they were able to
you know suspend enough people's
disbelief because some people really did
think that that was like based on a real
urban legend because it was real
pre-internet world or very early
internet so it was kind of hard to know
what was true what was it yeah you can't
really get away with that anymore just
because there's been so many found
footage movies but like i've seen some
good like hell house llc was a good one
um you know that i'm not you know
[ __ ] on the entire
found footage genre because i have seen
good ones
but you know wreck is a good one
obviously
a lot of this [ __ ] has to do with how
old you are when you first see it
too yeah you know in the context of the
time
you know yeah and
like you said it kind of you have to be
in the right mood yeah
to watch it i guess there was [ __ ] that
i was seeing in my [ __ ] early to mid
20s that
in those days at that age it was just
[ __ ] spot on
but you couldn't recreate those feelings
you got
back then yeah you know what i mean
seeing something for the first time you
know you're
we live in a world now where you know
visual imagery is so easy to produce
that you're almost just kind of
immune to seeing images
you know you're not impressed by
anything you see because cg
yeah you kind of took couldn't make
anything look like anything right so
it's not the same
you know which is kind of which is kind
of a shame it's kind of a shame yeah
we're not in that
we're not in that era anymore i mean
just go back and
look at music videos from the 80s like
old
billy idol music videos there's a lot of
energy there but you can really see
how cheap those sets were yeah you know
and the edits were real rough because of
the type of
the type of technology that they had and
you could do a better job now with no
money
with a phone yeah you know i mean i
could do it nowadays and i don't yeah
i'm
really shitty at videos right and and
those music videos made
tens of millions of dollars yeah tens of
millions of dollars they were [ __ ]
top videos
you look at them now there's really
nothing to them yeah well
yeah but [ __ ] man
the emotion and the energy was there and
it was real impressive to see that
on a screen you know when you were young
back in the 80s you know you're like
yeah that was the real deal there
was a top-notch video i still remember
like um
one of my favorite videos from back then
not necessarily one of my favorite songs
but one of one of my favorite videos was
that [ __ ]
that song by greg kinn that's what was
it was just called jeopardy right or
loves in jeopardy or something like that
i liked it because there was monsters in
it
but when i saw it the other day it's
like it it looks like it cost about a
buck 58 like to make it's
i think there was like [ __ ] it was
like tin foil and it was just like
really shitty makeup
and all this other kind of stuff what
about peter gabriel's video [ __ ]
sledgehammer with all the claymation
yeah that was like [ __ ]
i remember that one like all the awards
right i will say though that that
[ __ ]
that that [ __ ] aha video take on me
which one all those videos
that still looks cool nowadays yeah i
think yeah and that came out in 1984.
it held up it really did um just kind of
the the rotoscoping animation i guess
because it wasn't supposed to look
real necessarily but like all the
drawings and [ __ ] were really good it
was just really well executed
it was expensive back then it was yeah
and it was like i said it did win
all the [ __ ] videos but you can make
a lot of money with a music video back
then not anymore
well yeah it's like people don't even
see him nowadays i don't think
you know the guys that are making all
the money are independent guys that have
huge followings
yeah you know where they got new rapper
which is named tom mcdonald
tom mcdonald uh he's making a [ __ ] ton
of money and makes his own videos and
even goes on it but he's multimedia i
like how he did he even goes on his own
ghost hunts
yeah and you know his album's number one
outsold
eminem and uh he's just a dude on
youtube
yeah you know so you can do it now but
it's you're not going to command the
attention of the entire nation because
there's so much competition too much
competition
and you know it used to be the result
which is a good thing only a few
channels and then cable came and they
added a bunch more channels but most of
it was junk
it's just you know what i mean the
situation is different technology has
liberated everything
you can now sit at home and buy stocks
and [ __ ] and other people don't like it
now you know what i mean which all this
shit's amazing
you know it's becoming less
centralized it's more decentralized
network society it's not going to be a
top-down world anymore
and a lot of what you see a lot of these
old people who who you
who are in charge now who used to be
even more in charge
losing their [ __ ] because how they made
their
power and their fortune and everything
all that [ __ ] is going away
they're an endangered species it's going
to be a network society i see it coming
which that's a good thing for us that's
a very good thing for us
yeah stop listening to them
they know what they're talking about
louis said uh have you guys seen the
last
exorcism that's a found footage movie
that's pretty good um yeah i've seen it
it's
that is actually really good i had
forgotten about that one it's funny
because i always say it's like i don't
really like found footage movies but
then if i sit down and
think of you know good found footage
movies i'm like oh okay baby
i i can think of quite a few that i
thought were good i'm just saying that
it's so easy to make them that there's
so many
that aren't good you know but yeah yeah
the last
the last exorcism was actually really
good and it's i liked it because
it went in a direction i didn't expect
which a lot of them don't but um
so what else that's probably about it i
think that's about it yeah
it's not a complicated movie it's it's
it's worthwhile to watch
i pay five six bucks for it no no big
deal it's yeah it's very
feel good fun yeah very feel good movie
uh
fun for the whole family um
it's kind of old school in that way i
mean it's not it's not a movie that's
gonna be challenging your beliefs
or anything like that it's just a good
fun monster movie survival adventure
comedy horror
type thing and good music and i said i
kind of feel like everybody can watch it
there's no
there's nothing in it that's that would
like like be bad for the kids
it's trying to cast a very wide broad
net
yeah in the way that it's a crowd
pleaser yeah and
in the way that a [ __ ] really good
spielberg movie would have done back in
the eighties or something
yeah to get as many people to like it as
possible which
you know i think [ __ ] that's really
the way to go most of the time i i would
think i think that's a very safe bet
and people kind of miss those kind of
movies
because they're kind of comforting i
think that's why this this one did so
well
like on vod oh also i forgot to mention
uh jessica henwick is in this from
the marvel shows she was an iron fist
and yeah a couple of those she played
colleen right like on
iron fist and was she on daredevil i
think she's not daring too
but um yeah all right so i'm sorry you
guys
i guess that'll do it for hopefully
we'll be totally healed up next
show today yeah so tomorrow night we're
gonna do our drunken side tracks
yeah tomorrow at 5 pm i gotta get drunk
again
gotta get drunk and get sick
hopefully it'll be a good show though
yeah i don't know what we're going to be
talking about but we'll
uh yeah we'll think of something if you
guys can keep us rolling in the comments
and [ __ ] all you know
all could be able to come up with stuff
the past week the shows the past week i
think have been kind of rough to do
because we've been kind of sick
but uh you know i'm hoping the show will
pick back up
yeah i mean you know i haven't gone back
and watched them but i didn't feel all
that great making them i was sick get
out of anything
we'll see that's true and well the thing
about it is that you didn't really start
getting cranky until the very very very
end
you know what i mean yeah so it's a so
i'm getting fussy
he has to be quick because because i
just picture you as like a little baby
with like your face
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] here man okay
i know i'm the worst
all right so damn you're coughing up
like crazy i know sorry it's like making
me laugh making me cough
okay we both got the rona but
yeah we'll see you guys me sick
yeah you made me sick you were sick
before i was sick now i'm new to that
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah all right so we'll see
you guys uh tomorrow night 5 p.m eastern
standard time
so uh thanks for dropping by bye